paul besset ton salaire tu as
rémunération en ciel fait qu'à sa tête
d'épouser - ouais ça
[Musique]
ouais est-ce que tu m'en veux beaucoup
d'avoir fait ça sur toi je savais que tu
l'avais mal pris du coup on a une
embrouille c'est ça on a un litige à
régler mon gars a fait de m'agresser
comme ça c'est très désagréable si
vraiment tu veux qu'on règle le problème
moi je te propose qu'on règle le sait
avec nos champions je te propose qu on
règle ça directement sur red bull ne
joue pas avec les mots je parle du jeu
shadow les jo c'est le partenariat du
jour et c'est un [ __ ] de jeu monga
raid shadow les jo ne sais quoi c'est un
[ __ ] de jeu de rpg avec une histoire
de ouf et des graphismes tellement ofc
au début avec loïc on croyait que
c'était un jeu sûr hormis un loïc met
alors en fait c'est un jeu qui se joue
sur mobile à nohic ce jeu vous pouvez
jouer cinq minutes 5 heures autant que
vous voulez ce que vous voulez peu
importe en fait parce que vous faites ce
que vous voulez comme vous voulez il ya
toujours des trucs à faire d'un raid
shadow legends le de 400 champions
personnalisable que vous allez faire
évoluer qui vont avoir des nouveaux
styles des nouvelles attaques et qui
vont pouvoir tout en vrai ils font plein
de trucs et ça c'est cool et le
storytelling du jeu il est comment louis
et en téléchargeant le jeu avec le lien
qu'il ya dans la description vous
commencerez avec qu'ils n'ont pas dix
mille non pas vingt mille non pas 30
mais ils n'ont pas quarante mille mais
58 50 mille quoi si 50000 silver gratuit
et après cinq jours de jeu grâce au
nouveau programme des nouveaux joueurs
vous obtiendrez quoi loïc un super
champion épique à un epic championne
gratuitement et ça c'est avec le code
dans la description l'eau il se joint à
moi pour vous dire qu'on a aimé ce jeu
on a vraiment aimé on a vraiment adoré
oui c'est vraiment badass oh oui je vous
propose donc vivement c'est une
proposition libres de le télécharger
biais de liens qui lient à dans la
description pouvoir rendre des comptes
quand même les images que vous voyez
c'est vraiment les émotifs petit rajout
exceptionnel il vient d'avoir une mise à
jour qui va vous intéresser
entre le moment où j'ai filmé ce que
vous avez vu est maintenant le programme
nouveaux joueurs de red est passé de 7
jours à 90 jours c'est à dire que
pendant 90 jours où vous recevez les
récompenses gratuite en rouge
je vous avoue que j'aurais aimé avoir ça
pour commencer parce que je vous invite
vos champions préférés sega l un des
elfes noirs aussi parce que j'ai
commencé avec donc voilà je m'aime bien
et j'aurais pu le faire évoluer
rapidement parce que c'est ça que
j'adore dans ce jeu c'est qu'on peut
faire évoluer ses champions et donc
faire évoluer sa stratégie en fonction
de ça voilà je voulais juste vous l'avez
compris il ya quelques jours j'ai posé
une caméra dans le bureau relativement
discrètement qui allait avec le
grand-angle film et loïc et moi en
pleine discussion alors évidemment loïc
n'a pas trouvé ça bizarre que je pose
une caméra sur les étagères puisque je
le fais de temps en temps pour filmer
des vidéos pour faire des live donc
c'est pas c'est pas bizarre que je
posais une canne fortement pas dans ce
bureau l'idée c'était de me dire loïc à
une demande et je vais essayer de
désarmement t sa demande pour lui faire
croire que sa demande n'a aucun sens
alors que à la base évidemment loïc est
intelligent sa demande était fondée et
voir comment on peut avoir des
discussions mais les d'une forme de
confiance
essayez en fait de faire passer des
choses fausses pour des choses vraies
comme quoi personne n'est à l'abri la
preuve loïc a l'habitude de ça ils
connaissent mes vidéos parker puisque
c'est lui qui démonte donc il est à la
base rodez à l'esprit critique
voyons voir ce que ça donne ici bon par
rapport à ce que tu disais tout à
l'heure pour acheter la caméra nos
jeunes
oui du coup le truc donc je vous
explique la situation très rapidement
quand même loïc possèdent un
un appareil photo caméra s'appelle un
gh5 mais elle n'est pas pleinement sa
propriété c'est un achat qu'ils ont fait
1 2 avec un pote à lui est en fait il se
la partagent du coup suivant les
tournages de denis en l'occurrence et et
loïc et l'a récemment loïc mady par
rapport aux problèmes de planning qui
arrive rarement ce serait peut-être bien
qu'on en achète un nous pour nous ça
c'est son postulat de départ est en soi
il a pas tort je réfléchissais un mets
de base
toi t'as jaj 5 elle était à toi et à
denis en fait c'est un matériel partagé
on a chip et du coup toi pourquoi tu
veux que j'en achète une parce que lui
il s'en sert trop c'est ça avec eux ça
va faire un nombre donné on va on pourra
pas tourner comme on veut moi et puis
comme ça surtout on en a ici dédié à la
chose hockey puisque dans un sens même
si ça me dérange pas c'est pas grave
la caméra c'est moi qui l'avais acheté
en maniant l'utilisent fin je n'utilise
pratiquement que pour des tournages
ouais du coup c'est entre guillemets tu
enfin faudrait aussi quand on tourne
cure avec en avoir un spécial tu vois de
l'autre quelle est pour d'autres projets
donc dans un premier temps ce que je
fais c'est lui demander quelles sont ses
arguments mais c'est pas dit aussi
méchant que ça parce que sinon ça
pourrait le bloquer un peu le braquer
donc je lui demande juste pourquoi déjà
tu voulais qu'il ya nouveau gh1 que donc
il nous refait son argumentation
il est même allé un peu plus loin que la
première fois quand il me l'avait dit
parce que là en fait il m'explique que
deux bases la caméra qu'ils ont acheté à
deux il s'en sert foule pour mes
tournages quasiment et que du coup en
gros c'est pas si couple que ça parce
que c'est comme un peu si c'était la
mienne alors qu'à la base c'est la leur
ça il me l'avait pas dit comme ça la
première fois tu m'avais pas dit comme
ça la première fois qu il est vrai mais
ça se tient pour le moment non mais en
plus en ce sens dérange pas du tout et
c'est là où on fait croire une
acceptation oui oui en plus ça me
dérange pas du tout loïc est retourné
sur son écran en montage parce que pour
lui il n'y a pas de discussion pour
l'instant et c'est vraiment le but c'est
de reposer tout le terrain pour qu'on
reparle des mêmes choses et qu'il ait
pas l'impression qu'ils aient une
discussion qui va avoir lieu à ce sujet
c'est juste pour bien comprendre parce
que je te dis comment je vois les choses
pas moi en tant que fabien mais par
rapport à la boîte tu vois c'est que
pour moi c'est toi toi tu achètes
h5 soit je donne bc ton salaire tu as
une opération si elle fait passer de
tête et attend non mais en vrai c'est
passé par là cette norme est réglé donc
là on crée le choc
c'est très important qu'elle choque de
base et le choc tulle créé en allant sur
un truc qui est intolérable pour l'autre
personne est donc je commence par dire
attends il ya un truc qui me vois pas ce
que ce soit toi tu dois en acheter un
autre
soit je dois bc ton salaire tu a laminé
ration mensuelle en plus ça me fait rire
de le dire mais ça va ça me fait rire
aussi parce qu'à ce moment là en fait je
pense que ça s'est passé comme ça pour
toi là j'ai capté tout ton attention en
mode mais c'est pas possible qu'on aille
sur ces terrains là il peut pas me
baisser mon salaire à what's the funk tu
vois et c'est exactement ce qui est
voulu parce qu'après ce que je vais te
concédé ça va passer pour le coup pour
une concession de ma part et de faire
obtenir un statut quo de huy n'achetons
rien en fait
restons comme ça mais si je n'avais pas
créé ce diable la de il faut soit toi
que tu dépenses 1005 ou 2000 je crois ça
coûte soit soit toi tu dépenser 2000
soit je te veston salaire ça devenait
ces deux options possibles en votes
russie
en fait tu m'as dit oui nous travaillons
mois mensuellement je veux tu en es tu
vas les temps aussi parce que j'avais
une prestation de services complète avec
un outillage c'est toi qui depuis le
départ a amené de la chercheuse pour moi
à partir du moment où tu m'as dit
qu'après je me suis ok c'est cool parce
qu'en fait il a ses objectifs il a aussi
ses caméras à partir du moment où tu de
la puge une partie de la prestation qui
en moins parce que je veux dire ou alors
le plus simple pour moi si là je vais
juste sur ce passage là pourquoi loïc
est en train de réfléchir parce que ça
devient des arguments il doit y
réfléchir
sauf que je mêle du faux et du vrai par
exemple quand je lui dis depuis le
départ c'est toi qui as amené ta caméra
et ça c'est vrai en soi et donc bah pour
moi c'est inclus dans le prix que tu m'a
proposé avec tes objectifs takam tout ça
je me suis dit da tout son matos vote
depuis le départ il m'a dit qu'il avait
ses objectifs où il a toujours été clair
sur le fait que la caméra n'était pas à
lui pleinement et que il a ramené parce
que ça faisait des plus belles images
etc
mais il n'a jamais été dit de ta part
que la caméra était inclus dans ton
service mais comme ça se mélange de la
vérité du mensonge
il faudrait qu'on soit en embrouille
pour que tu as envie de faire du point
par point et tous séparés en fait tu
achètes top propre caméra
et elle tu appartiens foule à toi pour
ce projet là et comme ça moi je reste à
la même au même service que je celui
dont je bénéficie avec toi aujourd'hui
et toi tu peux continuer à t'en servir
pour aller sur tes autres projets alors
que si demain
allez ici à moi en plus tu devrais me
l'a louée pour d'autres projets annexes
quand tu fais des clips de rap d'être
comme ça même pas voir s'affronter ce
que six jeunes gens n'auraient quand
même un autre je prendrai le mien pour
je fais des projets annexes
mais celui-là il est dédié à issy quoi
donc moi quoi qu'il arrive en fait je
bénéficie puis de l'autre dont je
bénéficiais de cinéma aussi si vous on
est tu pourraient en bénéficier c'est un
tournage multi-caméras des choses comme
ça toi mais c'est juste là c'est plus
simple d'en avoir un qui est là
spécialement d'accord un point mais on
est d'accord que du coup la prestation
de certains qui a fait la station
service au complet si l'on redescend peu
en fait
allez un petit peu moins forte dans le
sens où c'est comme si au départ tu
avais eu ton ordi tu vois moi dès le
départ j'avais dit par contre faudra
fournir un ordinateur jeudi au québec
budgétisent moi et puis on achetait
écran les chats tour et on a tout acheté
toi il ya aucun problème avec ça mais du
coup par contre au départ tu as dit par
contre moi la caméra c'est bon les
objectifs c'est bon les cartes sd c'est
bon donc en fait pour moi au début quand
j'ai encore changer la version par
rapport à la version précédente
là on a angers pris comme exemple
l'ordinateur et j'ai ramené l'achat de
l'ordinateur au même niveau que l'achat
de la caméra alors déjà c'est
complètement faux ça depuis le départ
c'est à dire que moi j'avais une caméra
ai dit si tu veux tu entends je prendrai
la mienne qui est meilleure et par
rapport à ce que j'avais dit
précédemment là je reviens encore en
changeant une nouvelle fois la couche de
vérité de manière beaucoup plus direct
des mois au départ tu m'as dit voilà il
faudra acheter un ordinateur équipé par
contre la caméra c'est bon les objectifs
c'est bon les cartes sd c'est bon on n'a
jamais eu cette conversation loïc jamais
mais là comme tu avait acquiescé déjà la
première fois le premier niveau qui
mélangeait mensonges et vérités comme le
deuxième niveau est complètement
mensonge est en fait il valide parce que
c'est trop compliqué de revenir en
arrière surtout tu vas toi t'as juste un
besoin qu'on
on argumente avec le même argument
depuis le départ mais il ya des
variations qui font qu'au fur et à
mesure ça devient mind flex et c'est bon
donc en fait pour moi ta qualité de
compétence était aussi allié oui à un
matériel que d'amener je vois ce que tu
veux dire
sauf que c'était pas explicitement
lors donc c'est un tube autant de temps
d'argent parce que alors là tous pas que
le reformuler quand quelqu'un te demande
de faire un clip pour un certain budget
est ce que tu lui dis ben il va falloir
que toi tu me payes un truc si j'amène
mes caméras ou est-ce que tu prend en
otage cinq habituels non je dis je dis
je le dis le clip s'étend et si par
contre moi drame algérien de mon matos a
fait l défraiement du mato sont plus
qu'à six joueurs même pas le matos faut
louer pour une façon de remettre ça pour
ça je m'arrange qui va moi j'ai mon
matériel donc ça sera attentive à ce qui
s'est passé des coûts oui mais je
l'explicité au début mais pour moi dix
10 mois voire même un an de travail
ensemble ça devient explicite tu vois
c'est vraiment toi pour te la faire à
l'envers c'est ce chiffre que ce soit
juste quoi tu vois le moment où on
compterait argumente et que je vis c'est
pas porte la faire à l'envers etc loïc
féry ouais je sais c'est là où on joue
aussi sur la confiance entre deux
personnes donc dans l'absolu toi tu
préférais quoi s'il ya un choix à faire
ce serait acheté une nouveau matos ou ou
réduire ton salaire et là on revient à
cette technique de manipulation qui est
de lui donner un choix entre a et b
alors qu'il ya cdef ya plein d'autres
choix possibles mais de donner
l'illusion qui a qu'un seul choix entre
ces deux choses donc il lui un sentiment
de liberté même si les deux choix de la
range pas mais ça va me permettre
d'injecter plus tard le troisième choix
qui sera le choix qui sauvent en fait
serait-ce la nuit animé lui convient en
plus ce nom en bray si tu préfère
acheter du nouveau matos toi si tu
préfères taches noires gh5 qu'à toi du
coup on peut le faire passer par la
boîte ce qui fait qu'en plus d'économies
sera noté m là je commence à devenir le
sauveur
c'est dire si vraiment tu veux le choix
à moi je peux te tendre la main pour
t'aider à le payer moins cher mais ça
n'arrange toujours pas moi c'est pas une
dépense qui projetait à la base j'avais
un certain équipements ici qui était
satisfaisant moins satisfaisant que ce
que tu as toi mais comme à partir du
moment où tu va proposer de tourner pour
moi tu as ramené ton matériel suite en
disant on va utiliser savez ça à chaque
fois on voit pas projetés ça tu vois pas
ce que de la même manière il ya les
objectifs ya tout eu voilà je commence à
me positionner en victime
donc ça leur a même juste un petit
sentiment de culpabilité de ce mois
j'avais rien demandé en fait et c'est
toi qui as amené ça sur le tapis
du coup c'était quoi le truc des percées
et là on commence à avoir la vraie
embrouille dire que c'est le moment où
l'eau il dit mais du coup c'était quoi
le postulat de départ c'est à dire que
pour lui
ma conversation est légitime et il sait
plus trop pourquoi il voulait ça et ça
devient intéressant parce que je vais
pouvoir boucler deux trousses des fois
je tiens ma chance et je pense que le
mieux c'est que ce soit toi qu'ils
l'achètent pour toi et qui soit
approprié théâtre parce que sinon dans
un certain sens je me fais lésés par
rapport aux digues de départ même si
tout n'était pas explicite oui en fait
dans les faits c'est explicite
après ça fait comme ça une canne à ces
investissements que toi aussi tu on a
besoin si tu veux faire des trucs à
haute à gauche c'est un investissement
compris à droite à gauche c'est fait
génial parce que là intérieurement tu as
l'impression de m'embrouiller loïc qui
n'est pas moi du coup ça peut pas être
ma demande c'est là où tu vois on
rejoint le truc c'est que à aucun moment
ça peut être me demande à moi quand je
cadre aux seules ou quand je fais des
choses sales ok c'est exactement comme
cet ordinateur si t'étais pas là je ne
vais pas acheter de base tu vois sauf
que l'ordinateur qui m'a jamais dit moi
je veux rentrer chez moi à vitaly il
faudra quand je viendrai travaillé par
contre faudrait que tu achètes ça ça ça
parce que ça vous avez besoin pour vous
c'est on a acheté mais sur quasiment un
an tu m'a pas dit
un moment donné ma caméra gelant juin
relève du deal et faut que tu achètes
une oeuvre qui plus est la même il n'y a
même pas un apport en train prendra ses
nouvelles qualités tissant gambale mais
c'est encore moi c'est possible aussi
mais là je montre une ouverture assez
important puisqu'il apporte lui une
solution c je suis obligé de me montrer
ouvert à celle ci mais alors prélevé la
balayer mai et pour celles ci en urgence
d'accueil voilà le pour celle ci en
l'occurrence je ressente sur le sujet
douzy ponctué qui s'est rompu pour
épuisement du coup et vous plus de
discussions là il joue sa partie comme
on dit ils restent sur le choix s'est
donc c'est une vraie réflexion
d'investissement que je re balaye en dix
ans mais ça c'est une vraie réflexion
d'investissement donc le sous-entendu
c'est ce n'est pas ça notre conversation
actuel qui partenaires exactement des
petits partenariats comme celui
d'aujourd'hui
attention la vidéo commence à à 3,14
après t'es pas si c'est un poème de
thunes que toi tu peux pas te lâcheté la
grippe a sur le terrain de l'humour et
je ne l'est pas du tout suivi parce que
sinon on va décrocher de ce que je suis
en train d'essayer de mettre en place ce
que je peux comprendre
ben si ça tient doublant ses dires qui a
pas de manque
non mais si les deux sont à moi voilà
comment bien allez allez allez qu at war
et les quoi comme encore moins comme ça
mon petit couramment donc toi ça te
ferait il à toi à toi
parce qu'en fait sinon si ça devient un
problème en réflexion comme ça je me dis
pas d'intégrer ou quel était l'intérêt
de me demander d'en acheter un et là on
arrive à mon choix c'est à moi quel
était l'intérêt d'un acheteur puisqu'en
fait ça te fait doublon mais vous
imaginez bien que ça lui fait doublon
parce que je le force à aller sur le
choix entre a et b de il faut que tu
t'en as cetin toi même et donc lui il
répond assez légitimement benancin
ferait doublon et moi je récupère le sis
a fait doublon alors pourquoi tu vas en
acheter un mais à la base il voulait pas
en acheter avec voulait que j'en achète
un c'est là où ça commence à apprendre
son sens pour moi avec lui commence à
fatiguer mais ça se voit loïc que tu
fatigues
oui ouais voilà on en achète par l
angoisse comme mon ex aequo c'est
possible aussi nous dit juste pour
faciliter les choses pourquoi que s'il
ya 2 d2 tiens tourner avec avec denis 10
e dia pour de vrai mais techniquement on
peut soutenir j'en ai déjà j'étais moi
ça va j'ai compris a fallu en discuter
tout à fait ok hélas le teaser tu vas
finir dans le teaser fioul
merci grâce à toi et voilà comment nous
sommes arrivés à la conclusion qu'il ne
fallait pas du tout acheter de nouvelles
caméras puisqu'en fait il s'en ai acheté
il n'ya pas longtemps qu' il n'y a pas
de problème sur les tournages
habituellement etc en fait tout va bien
toi tu l'a ressorti comme en vrai ce qui
peut parler fort contentant de mai c'est
un mix entre oui bon effectivement alors
du coup il ya autant de besoins mais
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'ils
avaient besoin mais tu savais plus
pourquoi tu avais l'impression qu'ils
avaient besoin au départ c'est ça être
exactement ça en fait avec avec la
saturation de la logique
et puisqu'on argumenter contre
argumenter sur des arguments qui avait
plus rien à voir avec la situation de
départ tu pouvais pas très remonté le
fil de ta pensée pour tu vois ce que je
veux dire parce qu'en fait on
s'argumente est sur des choses qui
n'étaient pas bonnes à cause de ce
[ __ ] de choix a et b que j'ai inséré
dès le départ de swat en achètent une
seule je te baisse ton salaire qui t'a
fait loi de feuilles parce qu'on n'a
plus jamais reparlé de baisser le
salaire après tu vois et est ce qui fait
qu'à au moment de la libération avec le
nouveau choix tu dis bah oui en fait
pourquoi tu vois et c'est assez rigolo
parce que
rappelle quand même que le vrai truc
c'est pour qu'on ne soit pas embêtés
parce que déjà cette caméra là tu m'en
servais mais effectivement c'est un co
achats avec denis donc c'est du bonus
que j'en bénéficie de base ça c'est vrai
et ensuite ça veut dire qu'il ya
toujours une gestion entre les tournages
de denis et les biens et que nous on
n'en fait plus puisqu'on est toujours en
train de produire et donc assez
logiquement on devrait avoir une très
bonne caméra ici quoi tu vois et surtout
que l'argument secte a amené à un moment
donné d'en acheter une plus qualitative
était un excellent argument
donc on va s'acheter une nouvelle caméra
ok donc nous sommes très contents
d'avoir fait ce partenariat aujourd'hui
et donc tu vas pouvoir choisir une très
bonne caméra
voilà il pète et j'espère que ce type de
format là vous a plu si ça vous dit que
j'ai c'est de filmer comme ça des petits
moments de manipulation réel dans la
vraie vie avec des gens que vous
connaissez vous pas du tout dites moi
dans les commentaires ce sera cool et
après je vous cache pas qu'il ya des
petits trucs très rapides qui peuvent
être faits mais ça je le ferais
directement sur instagram que vous
pouvez rajouter ici apprenez 4 secondes
ça va vous détendre voilà merci beaucoup
je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué
aussi j'ai essayé de moins faire de
coupures et de moins détaillé moi parler
dans la vidéo ci ne demande que vous
m'avez fait plusieurs fois donc j'espère
que vous avez trouvé ça mieux mais
dites-moi si au contraire la s'était
passé chez eux le veut bien vos retours
voilà ça m'intéresse
sur ce je vous embrasse merci beaucoup
arrêtent d'avoir fait ce partenariat
avec nous n'hésitez pas à télécharger le
jeu pour soutenir ce genre d'initiative
c'est gratuit le lien est dans la
description avec tous ces avantages cela
j'ai sorti une vidéo sur la chaîne
secondaire la semaine dernière n'hésitez
pas à la voir aussi je vous mets le lien
dans la description à très bientôt
ciao